lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
obtener un poco de práctica observando y
analizando críticamente cómo las
personas manipulan polinomios y
expresiones algebraicas y la razón por
la que eso es útil es porque con mucha
práctica vas a poder analizar cómo es
que manipule hasta algunos polinomios y
encontrar en qué puntos de equivocaste o
si hiciste todo muy bien y en otros
momentos cuando estés leyendo un libro o
un artículo de ciencia o de matemáticas
y te encuentres que manipulan un
polinomio muchas veces lo que hacen es
decir sí y es súper claro que a partir
de esta expresión llegamos a esta
expresión y seguramente vas a querer
entender cómo le hicieron para llegar de
un lado a otro o si realmente tiene
sentido lo que dicen así es que es una
habilidad muy importante poder entender
cómo una persona manipula un polinomio
sobre todo si te parece que no tiene
mucho sentido lo que están diciendo y en
especial si tú
eres esa persona que manipuló el
polinomio es súper útil poder analizar
los pasos y averiguar si hay errores o
no y en dónde están
así es que pues vamos a empezar con este
ejercicio tenemos aquí 4x menos 3 por x
menos 2 al cuadrado y una persona a lo
largo de cinco pasos llegó a este
polinomio de aquí aunque hay lo que hizo
básicamente fue expandir este polinomio
ahora yo te recomiendo que lo pongas una
pausa al vídeo y verifique si estos
pasos fueron correctos o no ok y en el
caso de que haya errores hay que saber
exactamente cuáles son los errores bueno
suponiendo que ya lo intentaste por tu
cuenta
a ver empezamos por aquí pues en el paso
1 lo único que hicieron estas personas
fue tomar x 2 al cuadrado y escribirlo
como la multiplicación de x 2 x x 2
como podemos observar no pasó nada con
el otro paréntesis lo que hay aquí 4 x
menos 3 lo pasaron tal cual para acá así
es que por lo que observamos el paso 1
está súper bien bueno entonces vamos al
paso 2 el 4x menos 3 sigue igualito pero
lo que hicieron aquí fue multiplicar
estos dos paréntesis ya que
multiplicaron x por equis para obtener x
al cuadrado
después x x menos 2 y aquí están menos
2x y luego está por aquí menos 2 por
equis o sea menos 2x y finalmente menos
2 x menos
qué es 4 las fiestas que parece ser que
multiplicaron estos dos paréntesis súper
bien aunque hasta ahorita no tenemos ni
un solo error vamos al siguiente paso
aquí otra vez el 4x menos 3 sigue
igualito pero por aquí parece que
simplemente simplificaron esta expresión
de aquí aunque hay tomaron menos 2 x más
menos 2 x y lo escribieron simplificado
como menos 4x así es que este polinomio
de aquí está por acá sin ningún error
todavía y ahora cuando pasamos al paso 4
ahora sí van a involucrar a 4x menos 3
aunque al parecer lo que hicieron fue
multiplicar tal cual estos dos
polinomios no quería hacer esta
multiplicación algebraica y lo que
tenemos que ver ahorita es si
multiplicaron bien estos dos polinomios
o si se equivocaron
si es que tenemos por aquí 4 x x x al
cuadrado
eso es 4 x al cubo y luego tenemos 4 x x
menos 4 x y eso es menos 16 x cuadrada y
4 x x 4 o sea 16 x hasta este momento
todo el procedimiento está muy bien y ya
nada más nos falta multiplicar menos 3
por todo este paréntesis ya que hay
menos 3 x x al cuadrado eso es menos 3 x
cuadrada menos 3 x menos 4 x eso es 12 x
pero aquí no tienen 2 x aquí tienen
menos 12 x lograr y así es que aquí es
donde está el error
porque menos 3 x menos 4 x menos x menos
nos da más y entonces tenemos más 12 x
porque hay aquí tendrían que haber
puesto un más pero se equivocaron así es
que el error está en el paso 4 y bueno
luego tenemos menos 3 x 4 y eso es menos
12 esta parte está bien pero como ya se
equivocaron en este pedazo de aquí a
partir de aquí todos los demás
polinomios ya están mal pero lo podemos
arreglar de una forma no tan complicada
aunque hay porque aquí en donde más
afecta es a la hora de sumar 16 x + 2x
porque estas personas que hicieron este
procedimiento en lugar de sumar estos
dos números tomaron 16 x menos 12 x y xi
16 x menos 2x es 4x pero en realidad lo
que tenían que hacer aquí era tomar 16 x
+ 12 x
y eso es 20 8x entonces nada más tenemos
que poner 28 x el número de 4x y listo
ok pero el error estuvo en el paso 4 al
multiplicar menos 3 x menos 4 x en fin
hagamos más de estos ejercicios por aquí
tenemos otro ejercicio que se trata de
observar polinomios y determinar si
estas igualdades son válidas o no de
hecho este ejercicio lo saque de la
página de que an academy y queremos ver
cuáles de estas identidades son válidas
y elegir todas las opciones correctas
entonces vamos a empezar por aquí
queremos saber si 2 x mas x 4 x 2 es
exactamente igual a este polinomio de
aquí y la mejor forma de hacer eso es
empezar multiplicando estos dos
polinomios así es que tomamos 2x x 4x
eso es 8x cuadrada y luego tenemos 2 x x
menos 2 o sea menos 4x
y luego tomamos y lo multiplicamos por 4
x y eso es más 4x y guille por menos 2 y
eso es menos 2 de cuadrada ya ver qué
está pasando con este polinomio pues lo
que va a pasar es que estos dos términos
se van a cancelar ok pero pues sería una
muy buena idea verificar que tenemos
estos dos términos bien aunque ya ver
vamos a ver si lo hicimos bien tenemos
aquí 2x x menos dos de estos y es menos
4x y luego teníamos x 4 x eso es más 4x
entonces están bien y estos dos términos
se cancelan por lo que se empieza a ver
que no va a ser igual a este polinomio
cierto porque aquí ya no tenemos un
término
y aquí sí pero bueno vamos paso por paso
ahora lo que vamos a hacer es factorizar
12 de este polinomio que por cierto este
polinomio se reduce simplemente a 8x
cuadrada menos 2 de cuadradas pero si
factor izamos un 2 nos queda 4x cuadrada
menos de cuadrada y aquí ya podemos ver
claramente que estos dos polinomios no
son iguales así es que esta opción no la
queremos elegir esta no es una identidad
válida
ok bueno vamos con la siguiente igualdad
ahora queremos averiguar si n más 2 al
cuadrado menos n al cuadrado es igual a
4 por n 1 y para ver esto lo primero que
tenemos que hacer es desarrollar este
polinomio de aquí
n 2 al cuadrado es n al cuadrado
4 n porque vamos a tener 2 ene 2
n + 2 al cuadrado que es 4 y después nos
falta
este término de aquí que es menos en el
cuadrado pero la n al cuadrado se
cancela con la menos n al cuadrado y lo
que nos queda es 4 n 4 y si a esto de
aquí le factor izamos un 4 lo que nos
queda es 4 por n m más uno más uno o sea
esto que teníamos por aquí así es que
esta identidad si es válida
vamos con la última igualdad pero voy a
necesitar más espacio para volver vamos
a multiplicar estos dos tenemos a por 2
a eso es 2 x al cuadrado luego tenemos a
por 1 esto es simplemente
y luego tenemos ve por dos a jesús 2 a b
y b por 1 que es b y finalmente tenemos
este término de aquí menos b estos dos
de aquí se cancelan y lo que nos queda
es 2a cuadrada más a más 2 sabe ahora
por aquí podemos ver que tenemos una
factor izada entonces pues podemos
tratar de hacer lo mismo por acá así es
que si factor izamos una a este término
de aquí va a ser 2 a esta de aquí va a
ser simplemente un 1 y este término de
aquí va a ser simplemente 2 p
y esto de aquí es exactamente lo que
escribieron por acá lo que hay solo que
en otro orden tenemos 2 a 2 a más 2 b2b
más 11 entonces esta identidad es válida
bueno espero que esto haya sido una
muy buena práctica lo que hemos hecho
aquí es encontrar cuando dos expresiones
son iguales o no que es súper útil para
encontrar errores especialmente para
evitar que tú cometas errores o por lo
menos encontrar en dónde están y bueno
ojalá que también lo disfrutes